we're here on the Internet's and we're
gonna read some cards from the people
but first what happened you you said
something in their mad at you I know
this feeling but what you what what the
thing you said about the Saudis you were
making a joke and it went too far we're
sorry
he said we're getting blowback on
Twitter or something okay well I mean I
I saw your face what I said it I didn't
even realize that I had 12 cups of
coffee I regret saying it okay there you
go
I mean you know it's like everyone's to
everyone's to-to-to-to you know I mean
it's a live show you don't really want
to see the president just members by the
Saudis
I don't you know I don't like Donald
Trump either but yes we you know I had
Kathy Griffin on and I said no I don't
know it was fine yes I said we should
forgive Kathy Griffin but I don't
endorse what she said either or did you
know it was not the right thing in
medical depression right okay but about
who but who the president is we do not
want physical harm saying it right
regret that everyone misinterpreted it
yes they misinterpret everything right
[Applause]
I'm very happy I'm not on Twitter I
never said the Beatles were greater than
God or that was better than him there's
a thing or whatever it is and now it's
all this okay James kurchuk do you think
the way mayor Pete speaks about religion
God and morality will have any on the
religious right rethinking their support
of Trump no I think it's incredible that
the first real serious gay presidential
candidate has this totally bourgeois
domestic life happily married very kind
of you know normal if we can use that
term and as a religious guy whose quote
scripture and he's running against a
heterosexual president who's been
married three times is a pagan is yeah
that's worth using
[Laughter]
very often no he's a heathen I don't
know about a pig yeah what you mean -
drew its money bro you're having sex
with a porn star Trump is the one that
the evangelical Christians support in
spite of all that and here you have this
guy who's you know he's gay and that's
his fault I guess right it's like
everything else he's totally by-the-book
but see I think this goes back to the
debate about abortion I think that
what's happening with the ventricle
right is they have an attitude towards
women and the issues about women's
empowerment they have an attitude about
racism and other issues and his
strongest group of support in the
country is evangelicals how do you
explain that there's a long game he
still gets exactly and he's delivering
undergone being anti-choice that is what
they that is a bargain they made it's
not about religion he's silent keeping
women and it connects to Saudi Arabia
and Iran where theocracy theocracy turns
religion into power and that is the this
aspect of the Republican Party is a
theocratic party that would enshrine
religion as a power that would take away
rights from in this place right I mean
in other words people who don't have
health care or the farmers who are
getting screwed by the tariffs but but
it's a bigger noble cause right in that
in that way and so there's also you know
you're part of this grand this grand
narrative but the really corrupting
thing is power becomes their end yeah I
mean why not you know you get the
feeling when they start rewriting the
rules after or Democrat wins the
governorship of Wisconsin that the norms
are all gone because power is the is the
end and so it justifies anything and you
don't feel that there's a higher
morality that they're in pursuit of when
they're passing is abortion Allah it is
a Power Move
that's saying we control the legislature
so we will control you and okay Fran
what are your thoughts on the New York
Times story about Trump losing over a
billion dollars in one day
okay I think he was the Biggest Loser
they said of all the tax payers in that
ten amazing and this one or two or three
years mr. brilliant business what you
think of that I mean am I surprised here
that no I mean no one Trump lost New
York City New York City nine to one
right nine to one because it's a place
where people most knew him okay and that
is why and so you know every no one in
New York you thought he was a real
secret I mean there any Republican to
lose not nine to one not nine to one yes
I mean the Upper East Side which
traditionally often votes for
Republicans for you know president say
Chris they don't pay taxes or they
weren't even less than no taxes but for
Hillary Clinton okay because no one in
New York's no one who can make enough
money to afford to live in New York City
and pay the taxes there is stupid enough
to vote for that looks like Bill
DeBlasio Bill DeBlasio Ronnie the
president seventy six percent of New
Yorkers don't want him to run of his own
constituents no one ever said anything
that cuz I met in New York what we had
bill on I like Bill what what goes
through a guy's mind when there's twenty
two people in the race I think those
literally thinking there's a mayor of
South Bend Indiana is doing really well
and I represent a place that is like
twenty times three hundred times as
large and have to make them your
decisions I think the size of the crowd
is actually making more and more people
it seems like there's seven or eight
potential realistic presidential
candidates there's maybe fifteen who are
running to get a TV show or a radio show
or a book deal and then there's better
O'Rourke who's like having a midlife
crisis and I'm just asking why you put
it I mean he just reminds me of these
guys I went to school with who likes
wrote a lot of dope and pretended to do
the reading nothing against those guys
there are some of my closest friends but
they shouldn't be resident
I like that out too but I did Tara Manu
[ __ ] for all the apologizing that's
yeah it's really really you know if you
keep saying sorry you look like a sorry
candidate they're okay the one thing I'd
say is if you're actually thinking about
what Democrats have to do the fact that
Texas was a two and a half point race is
an important issue so whatever Democrat
who ever took Cruz unlikeable man in
America higher support in Texas than
John Cornyn does right now
he actually conservatives like him we
don't understand it but they like him
and I actually think if you're thinking
about these things having having cuter a
candidate in Texas suit as well having a
lot of candidates who a Latino candidate
maybe he brings more Latinos into the
primary getting more and more people
interested in the primaries actually a
bit because I think sherrod Brown Barry
Brown the senator from Ohio yes what
about him is so different than the other
23 he first of all he's like what am I
getting from him that I don't see what
Amy Klobuchar he doesn't throw staplers
he's a liberal Democrat I like the two
wins in Ohio who speaks she wears in
Minnesota Ohio is a temper Ohio stuff
okay yeah and he's a good guy he's
interesting I wish he'd run well no
don't say that we're taking the sign-up
sheet down okay for the soccer team Yeah
right
the voter it's very different so
Democrats are very focused and one thing
that's so focused I think it's very
tough love it's very different from 2016
Democrats actually don't want candidates
ripping each other apart they actually
are trying to make the time I get it
every time
Joe Biden reason why Zuma is because
people want a safe candidate they don't
want it he's saying I can attack other
Democrats Democrats who attacked other
other candidates have actually come down
on the polls that is a sign of a
rational party that has identified
Donald Trump Bernie
there's not a dent recessive like in
other words we're trying to figure out
what our message is when last time we
had one candidate in a certain way and
now we have these disparate messages and
so if this process leads us at sixteen I
understand we had a lot of people
running in 2000 saying that that's part
of the problem when you have so many
people running for the nomination what
what they're concentrating on now is
it's not how to win the election their
country's running out how to separate
themselves from these other people what
is my lane what can I do to make myself
stand out I mean that's why bet out did
his reboot right that's why some of them
like suddenly take a stand like wow I
want to get every gun out of America
because then I'll be that guy really
it's really it's gonna be when people
start dropping out of the race will they
will people join forces or will people
be I mean it really depends how long
people join for they join for I think
actually as you said earlier the
Democrats are super focused on
electability which means actually trying
to make an argument about how you can
win the general election not just but
they look like clowns when you when you
have 20 people I mean if you have a
debate they're gonna have to have three
nights first they were gonna have two
nights who's now it's Coachella yes
because that's a music festival this is
just but would you watch three nights of
debates now with nine people every night
or something chasing electability
because the Democrats end up going for
someone they think other people like and
it turns out nobody likes the person
they they should vote for the person
they like not the person who's
supposedly going to win because no one
knows who's but I agree that it's a long
process I agree that I think people
demonstrate ability in that one fortune
cookies for everybody thank you very
much
you